[Snoring] Hello, Chemulten
members.  This is the
Chesley Morning Brief for Monday, June 29th, sharing happy investment moments
.  Did you have a good weekend?   I will
start with a part.  First, let's look into this with
Director Wang of the Chinese Market yesterday, Friday
.   yes
.  While urging Asian stock markets to follow suit, the
index fell by 2.25%.   The
Heungseong index fell by 4% to -3.4%
.  If you go up to the triple yoke room on a large scale, you will be fine
.  Looking at the sectors, the floating
energy sector was strong, but the
communication and handmade
industries weakened.
Last Friday, dividend defense
stocks went up.  Jang Geum Youth
rose by 1.25%, Hwan Su by 1.4%, and
Guto Youth's spirituality rose by 5%.
And I
also assessed household-related stocks due to the victory of consumption and the strengthening of currency exchange policies
.  It went up by about 2.7%
.  Following the expansion of global semiconductor companies' capacity,
IT
market share stocks showed strength.  Beopwha
Hwacheon is said to rise by 1.9%, Jongdo tax by
3.5%, and Jeomcheon Taike
has risen by 1.5%.
Due to the subsidy for the cooking ship supply, the
officials probably kept coming up with strange stories like additional increases for about
a week.  Chunggu
Geoseon is going up an additional 7%,
Honghwa Tech 7%, Jungdae Tech 5%, and
Hwat 300%.  We need to
place an order for that CCR this week due to an additional increase
.  There is a possibility that Kinboard
[snorles]
that Wednesday, Thursday, there is a chance of a price increase
.  Market expectations
are around 15% rather than 10%.   If
something is raised by 15%, that could be the best-case
scenario.
To the company.   yes
.  that's right.  The growth business can be
applied as a major restriction to the industry
.   Stocks
related to the solar sphere also showed strength.  Oh, Jeonseung Gijeon
recorded a 3.3% increase, and DCR Jonghwa recorded a 10% increase.   On
the other hand, a significant number of A's related figures were
omitted.  Approval Tech fell 7%,
Hojeon Jusin fell 5%, Jungje 5000 fell
5%, and Sinyeok fell 73% 7.3%
.  Oh, the specific interest rate for the belief product
was 0.8PB, which is 8b.  The specific interest
rate for related items was -1.2bp, and the
foreign exchange rate
was slightly lowered.
thank you  [Sneer] Regarding the
Chinese market these days, do brokerage firms in China
release monthly strategies, daily market conditions, or similar data like in Korea? Hmm,
are you referring to a brokerage firm in the military?  No,
regarding the Chinese market in China... ah, yes.   yes
.  yes.  There is some comment.
So, what is the most interesting issue in China these days,
considering the optimal short-term period—like
a week or a month
?
XMT is growing.
Ah, TXMT.   yes
.  yes.  that's right.  CXMT.   It's
TXMT, right?  yes.  Regarding the C
CXMT Changshin sell orders and Nesin, does the
interest mean you are wondering
how significant a supply and demand impact it will have on the stock market,
or how the market capitalization will be formed if it goes up
?
yes.  you're right.
Regarding that, then overall, for those who are
already investing in the Chinese market,
yes.
Uh, is the CXMT listing
good news?  Is it a bad omen?  Step by step, well, there is quite a lot to
talk about regarding this.  If Sex MT
grows, there might be some supply and demand issues
.
Well,
because right now, the target is going fast,
almost around 3 trillion, but lately, we are
looking at 5 to 7 trillion.   They are even
talking about up to 10 trillion.  If you
calculate the total cost of the reconnaissance gun, it comes out to about 2,002 trillion.
2 quadrillion
won... hmm, there is a
possibility.  Because
[clears throat] we can earn about 40 trillion next year, and
almost all stagnant semiconductor companies have increased by more than 50 times
.
Even so, if you rewrite the lyrics, it could yield 10 trillion
.   If
you get 10 trillion, you
can get out of there right away after taking a break.  Because next week, there is
no stock that goes up or hits the upper limit on the day.
So that's right.  So, usually with an IPO like this, since the number of
shares isn't that large, the price can probably
double or triple on the same day
.  Shall we go?  So, this
supply human is a bit big.  If we consider 20 trillion and 10 trillion, the share of
fertilizer in stagnant and prosperous politics could exceed 10%.  The
impact is quite significant.  Other than that, if this luxury is in
harmony, the maintenance owner can handle the maximum effort
.  Because you have to invest the money you received
right under the maintenance company
.  That is why people are saying that
maintenance is good these days, as you also purchase maintenance
.  That is correct.   Has the
exact listing date for CXMT been
set?
There is content among the updates from last Friday.  Uh,
when we win in July, it seems like the
submission of that report will probably be finalized
.  So, starting from the second half of July, the
subscription period is very short, and if you finalize it, it is the
end of July. Yes, that is how the
current discussions are going
.
All right.  You
briefly mentioned before that it was around 2 trillion, and while the profit scale is
quite a bit lower compared to Samsung Electronics or SK Hynix,
since it receives a high multiple, the
market capitalization could potentially be formed at a similar level
.   He
conveyed those words.   yes
.
yes.  I'm going to look at the trending stocks.  uh.   yes
.  Is it an admission application?   Is
it precise?   yes
.  That's right.  Recently,
I know a lot about Friday, and last week, that early... was it Wednesday or
Tuesday? You
introduced it once, yes, that's right.  Another related
[clears throat] report
has come out.  My fortune telling was
about 9% accurate last Friday.
Since the minimum price for the Chunggu technique is 10%, it has almost
gone empty.   A
comment regarding that has been released.
First off, regarding that loss, well, everything came out before, and there was
no Taebae.  The
reason I'm dumbfounded is because of Apple.  Looking at the GP Work
report, Apple's
stock price fell a bit due to concerns about declining sales following price increases for MacBooks and iPads
.  However, it maintains the iPhone price
.  Recently, regarding that
ambassador, it was judged that the original plan was an excessive measure as the improvement in iPhone launch
visibility and product mix was confirmed
.
Hmm,
there is also a possibility that preparations for the iPhone launch market qualifiers will be successful.  And regarding the
Promax product, you know, we are
expanding the sales ratio in this area
.  Therefore, the company
has the potential to improve its margins.  Originally, the
8x payout 1 UT contraverter
is scheduled to launch starting from the second half of this year.  Well, we have been
agreeing on the telecommunications equipment business revenue for next year and the year after
.  You know how Gusas Reaper appears before, too
.  We are viewing Gusas similarly
. We expect these gears to be around 10% and
12%, respectively.
So, originally, next year's rankings
were estimated at 21.3 billion, 28 billion, and 37 billion respectively, and
have risen by about 1%, 4%, and 11% compared to the previous year.  If Takedo
applies that 25x multiplier next year, the TP is
set to be around 97.   It has
risen by about 18% compared to the previous week, and it
could even rise by 40% compared to last week's gold price.   hmm.
[Snorting] Anyway, this is the item you covered a day or two
ago, but was it
last Thursday that you covered it again?  I
remember mentioning to Yuri Pro at the time, when Apple's stock price in the US was down about 6%, that even if they raised prices, their loyal customers would still buy. However, it
seems that in reality, some in the market are concerned that if Apple raises prices, demand will decrease.   that's
right.  I kept the iPhone.
Because this company's main business is the
iPhone.   Things like
Mapp are all being
driven by the company.  I recently
asked someone around me, and they think there is a possibility that
pricing for things like MacBook Ads could be somewhat affected
.  The demand for replacement is
different from that of the other Apple products.  The elasticity of demand.   that's
right.  that's right.  The price
has increased significantly.   hmm.
However, since the issue coming out that weekend is that
CXMT is talking about being able to buy that iPhone additionally, I
actually think it might be confirmed.   yes
.
All right.  But then again,
once you raise the price like this,
over time it becomes the base price, so that is
correct.   yes
.  I think I
mentioned this during the first part of the Morning Brief sometime ago, but I also
bought a computer tower for work and was
shocked by how much the price had gone up.   It
seems like this happened due to memory prices, and it
appears that what is called die chip inflation is affecting all companies in both positive and negative ways.
All right.  Since there were such important
issues, he/she has once
again summarized and updated the situation in a few days
.   Let's
move on to the United States.  Let's find out
how the US market performed last Friday
with YuriPro.
20 [Clears throat] I will now
report on the US market on Friday, the 26th
.  First, looking at the overall index, it was
mostly flat
.  SMP 500
finished with a 0% decline, down 0.505%, Nasdaq fell 0.24%, and the decline was slightly less at 0.09%.  However, it was a
day where internal sector trends were more important than the index itself.  While
interest rates and oil prices themselves have come down a bit,
within the stock market—as I
mentioned below—short-term financing conditions have tightened as the SOFA rate and
IRB spread
narrowed to about 1b-1bp. Additionally, as equity
financing
costs rose due to increased borrowing demand from memory GTFs, margin accounts, and hatch funds, profit-taking occurred in
AI and semiconductor positions that had been somewhat overheated, so it
seems fair to say that the market loosened up a bit.  I have
brought these one by one to go over them and show you what text is available. First, if you
look at the oil price levels in the figure on the right, I have included data covering the period from
Friday's market through the weekend and up to
today.   In the
case of WTI, it was around $70 per barrel, and
Brands
was around $72.  During Friday's trading
session, it actually showed a downward trend from the $72 range
to the $69 range, but
over the weekend, it
rose back up to the $70 range.  Over the weekend, as
tensions related to the Middle East resurfaced,
there was some movement in oil prices in the futures market; however,
after the market closed, there were reports from a media outlet called Axis stating that
Iran would continue to refrain from further clashes with the U.S. and
maintain dialogue channels
.  So, although it
showed a stable trend again, according to this media outlet,
citing a U.S. official, it is reported that the U.S. and Iran have agreed to suspend
mutual protection attacks in the Gulf region
.  And while there were
reports last week that both sides agreed to establish a line between the U.S. and the Revolutionary Defense Forces during the summit, the related
reports seem to be conflicting.   In
that
regard, it
appears to be repeating these ups and downs without rising sharply or going up significantly.
Since the uncertainty regarding the Sea of ​​Hormuz has not completely disappeared yet, although the oil price risk premium itself has
decreased, some tail-side
risks still remain. Therefore, I would say that the final direction depends on
confirming Trump's remarks
.
Now, if you look at interest rates as well, they were
somewhat stable on the surface.  The 10-year yield has
dropped to the 37% level, down from 4.37%.  With oil prices now coming down,
looking solely at the macroeconomics, it did appear to be a somewhat favorable environment for risk assets and the
stock market
.  yes.
However, as I
mentioned earlier regarding the SOFA rate and IORB,
since supply and demand have become somewhat more competitive, I think we can reiterate that the risk level in the
overheated sector of the stock market may have
increased significantly in this regard
.  So,
connecting this trend,
if you look at the semiconductor sector, semiconductors were weak.  Okay,
there is an ETF called SMH that groups together semiconductor companies, and I mentioned it in the text
.  This one
fell by about 3% to 4.3%, and Credo Technology, which has a
product line in the data center networking sector,
also
fell by about 10.7%.  Now,
amidst a similar trend, memory and
equipment stocks were also a bit weak.
In the case of Micron, it fell by about 6 to 7 percent,
Applied Materials by 6.2 percent, and
Min Seon-chi by a similar amount, while
SanDisk dropped by about 5 percent to 10.5 percent
.  On the other hand, I believe I mentioned last week that the
semiconductor and big tech sectors were moving in somewhat opposite directions, but the
big tech sector has actually
rebounded slightly.  As I
mentioned recently, it seems necessary to view the emerging
weakness in memory semiconductors in connection with the current trend of strength against Big Tech companies. While
issues regarding rising memory prices continue to surface, which is generally
favorable for the semiconductor industry as it absorbs the supply and demand, the
burden of costs
appears to be the primary factor for Big Tech firms like Apple.  However, if we
look at why Apple rose, it appears that
on Friday's trading session, rather than the
burden of these costs themselves, the fact that Apple is
proactively securing such supply chains
was interpreted positively, unlike the sentiment that had grown somewhat negative in the semiconductor sector
.  So, it
seems reasonable to interpret that the acceptance of the company as one capable of defending margins even in an environment of continuously rising costs contributed to the increase in its stock value.  And
regarding individual semiconductors, I
mentioned On Semiconductor in the text below
.  As I
looked at the stocks that have fallen significantly, this stock was the
first to catch my eye, having plummeted by about 24%
.  On Friday,
there was a report that a company called Synetics was being acquired through a 7 billion dollar all-stock exchange and some other method.  However, while the downward trend is significant when
viewed solely in terms of numbers, if we
consider what you always say, Mr. Manager, is the scale of the acquisition in comparison, it seems reasonable when
looking at the size of the acquisition relative to the market capitalization. The
important point is that
from On Semiconductor's perspective, it appears to be due to the
dilution effect from the stock issuance rather than a cash outflow.
If the
structure involves issuing new shares worth about $7 billion relative to the market capitalization, the
market can be reflected at around 20%
.   It
seems that this move can be viewed as reflecting a discount on the complexity associated with the acquisition.
Healthcare is also attracting attention as it moves in a direction opposite to that of semiconductors, and the
healthcare sector has been quite strong.
I've been going back and forth a bit.
Now, if you look at the SMP healthcare sector,
unlike other stocks, it has
risen significantly by about 3.16% to 6%. I checked
the percentage of rising stocks in the sector on Bloom this morning, and it has
increased quite a bit to around 88%.  It seems that
rather than just a few large biotech companies like Moderna rising, major
pharmaceutical companies and the biotech sector in general rose together
.  Since
approval is a crucial factor in the biotech sector, I
initially thought it might be FDA approval season;
however, rather than approval season, it appears to have been a market
driven by individual issues involving large companies
.  Mila
Lilly rose by about 7%, Johnson & Johnson by
4%, and AbbVie by about 4.2%,
but in the case of AbbVie, there
was a particularly strong individual issue.
There is a medication here with specific characteristics, and I heard it has received
FDA approval as a treatment for digestive issues and arthritis for children aged 6 and older
.  So, it appears that the
emergence of such positive issues, coupled with M&A opportunities in the
bio sector, led to a significant surge
.  So,
there were some individual news items like this, and I would also like to point out that it was a rotation market where
funds withdrawn from semiconductors and AI moved into large pharmaceutical or biotech sectors
.
Additionally, if you look at the bottom right,
Lucid surged by about 6% to 15.6% in the automotive sector
.  There were already
expectations for a robot taxi collaboration between Uber and Nuro
.  However, after this expectation had already been reflected once,
the stock price was somewhat
suppressed as the slowdown in electric vehicle demand and the risk of capital depletion came to the forefront, but there was an
announcement regarding restructuring last Friday
.  So, I think we can
point out the issue as the rebound likely occurred as expectations for cost reductions became more prominent.
However,
the news of workforce reductions can be interpreted
as a defensive measure rather than a signal of long-term growth
.  So, for that
reason,
rather than saying a turnaround is confirmed, it seems more accurate to view this as a rebound driven by a combination of cost-cutting expectations and
shock coverage
.  I have
discussed quite a few things today, but to summarize, while the
index itself remained flat on Friday, there
were significant internal changes.   With
reports of attacks on the U.S. emerging, the
superficial macro environment itself
was favorable.  However, now that the gap between the
SOFA rate and the IRB spread has
narrowed significantly and the rise in equity financing costs has
become more prominent, internal market supply and demand has
tightened.  So, as a result,
profit-taking occurred in the somewhat overheated AI and semiconductor sectors, while conversely, it was a market where
funds shifted to healthcare and some specific stocks
.   The
US market is closed this Friday for Independence
Day.   The
U.S. employment figures are released on Thursday night, the last trading day in the U.S.
Therefore, since
employment indicators and interest rate directions could be re-evaluated and
the results
could be immediately reflected in the Korean market on Friday, the key
factor after today's market close will likely be
how much profit-taking in the US semiconductor sector subsides.
Even if there is weakness, the key
variable for assessing the sustainability of this rally going forward will be how well the fundamentals of the companies themselves, as well as the fundamentals and supply and demand of the domestic semiconductor sector, can absorb the weakness in the US semiconductor market.   That's all
. Um,
thank you.  Then, will this week's employment
figures be
reflected in the US market on Thursday?  Or,
since the employment figures are released after the US market closes on Thursday (US time),
was the regular market downturn not reflected?  Since it's closed on Fridays.  Uh, I
understand that the regular session is not being reflected
.   hmm.
Then, looking at US market futures and
such, it will likely be reflected in the Korean market in advance, but it
seems the US will reflect it next Monday.
That's true.  After listening to you, it
seems that the stocks that were very hot have fallen significantly. However, Apple has
rebounded, Microsoft, which had been slumping, has risen by
nearly 6%, and
software companies like Palantir and M-Robin are also seeing a
rebound. Even though
there are clearly leading stocks in the market, if
non-leading stocks have fallen to prices where their fundamentals are
not being reflected excessively, there should
be a rebound as well. I
would like to understand it from that perspective.  Rather than an adjustment, I will wrap things up
like this.  I even
looked at the US market.  Let's take a look at
how the virtual asset market performed, including last weekend, with
Chief Juyeok.  yes.   I will
tell you about the time.  If
you look at the 72-hour timeline first, [snorting] you will
see that despite the attacks between Iran and the US being halted, there is not much of a reaction
.  So, the market continues to show a pattern where prices do
not particularly react to positive news but react more strongly to negative news
.  I think you can view it like this.   There was
some volatility last Friday, and since the
attacks began on that day, the
negative factors regarding the start of the U.S. strike against Iran
were clearly reflected.  In fact,
when we saw that there was no significant reaction to the statements made early this morning by the U.S. and Iran saying they would stop the attacks, I suspect that the market itself does not
trust the stance taken by the U.S., Trump, and Iran
.
I strongly thought about that while looking at oil prices.   If
you look to the right, this is the oil price chart for the weekend
.  When I looked at the chart over the weekend, as you
explained so eloquently earlier, there was almost
no change and absolutely no significant shock movement
.  Therefore, I
personally believe that the market is betting to some extent that the conflict between the U.S. and Iran will be prolonged, and that they are managing the situation
sufficiently to ensure that it does not escalate further as it becomes a long-term affair
.  So, this time too, an
attack occurred over the weekend.  Oh, they went out of their way to
report it again. They originally planned
to announce it earlier, but pushed it back to the weekend
.  Oh, I saw reports like this
coming out as well.  So, looking at this, it does
n't seem like it will end easily.
And I think we all need to acknowledge it, and even
all investments are
acknowledging it.  I
think we just need to acknowledge that these things are being reflected in the investment.  If you look at that PD, it is
still recording around 18 in the Extreme Fear section.
If you look at the spot ETF rankings, there
was an outflow of about 1.14 billion years just on Thursday and Friday, and
about 1.79 billion years over the past week. So, you can
consider the past week to have been a week with significant outflows. While there had
been signs of the trend easing slightly over the past two weeks, you can
see that a large outflow occurred once again last week.  The one at the
bottom left is the Crypto Ashes
consensus.  So, who is
seeing a downturn?  So, since I
have posted a lot, you
can consider me an analyst who forecasts how the price of Bitcoin or crypto will turn out. This
is a chart showing the rankings from 1st to 10th place in order of accuracy.  So, if you look from top to bottom, there are only
three bulls predicting a strong trend.  You can consider that the
strength has also
dropped significantly.
So,
when I spoke about this last time, around March, I think I can confirm that the
consensus was roughly half bullish and half bearish, and if you
look at the prices at that time, they were
very good.  So, are
n't those factors currently being reflected? Since these analysts are constantly
monitoring price trends and changing their
forecasts to issue new ones, I
personally think we need to be aware that analysis articles influencing the price will likely emerge.
Nevertheless, those forecasting a bearish market are largely predicting a downturn, and the
percentage of those forecasting a bearish market is
over 70%.  You can
consider it to be over 70% based on the top scores
.  I
wrote on the right whether the current situation would continue, and since there is a
chart from Bloomberg released over the weekend, I
took a look.  Uh, you can consider the part at the bottom as the
supply and demand for semiconductor-related ETFs
.  And
regarding the chart above, you can view it as an outflow from gold or Bitcoin ETFs
. Since the chart is moving downward rather than upward, you
can consider it an outflow; ultimately, almost all of this
supply and demand is being sucked into Bitcoin, or rather, the semiconductor sector
.  You can
view it exactly as [clearing his throat]
.  I think I can confirm that it shows an exact inverse relationship, based solely on this
year
.
So, considering the situation with Geumjok as well, it is difficult to view the current fund speed
prices as favorable, so
aren't those factors already being sufficiently reflected?  In any case, I
believe that precious metals are currently heavily influenced by the dollar index
.  Uh, regarding the major events, I
think I can simply bring two charts and explain this.  Hey, I
wrote "this time is different" in the title
. You can view this as a bit of satire directed at people who say, "
This time is different," when dumping ratios on assets—whether Bitcoin or stocks—that are currently undergoing significant corrections due to this bullish trend
.  So, regarding the Bitcoin
44-year realized price risk-to-reward
ratio, there is some data available on Crypto Cont
.  You will likely be able to see that every four years, the
blue bar chart suddenly
rises sharply
. The part where this bar chart rises
sharply and spikes
indicates that the reward-to-risk ratio I invested in was at its highest point
.  So, it seems you
can confirm that this was the bottom point
.  If you had bought it at this time, the
compensation rate would have been the highest.  I
think we can verify this, but
actually, we didn't bring this data to match this
.  There is still a little left.
Since there is still an hour left until we reach the experimental price, that is, the average unit price of the people, I think the range could go from $52,000
to around $48
.  When the emergency compensation
ratio reaches that section, we expect to see a trend where the chart suddenly
jumps, confirms a low point, and the compensation
ratio increases slightly
.   If
you look at the chart on the right,
the proportion of losses for long-term holders is recording an all-time low
.  So,
people who hold onto things for a long time—I think I would call
those who do it for two years or longer—long-term
holders.
Rather than actually determining whether the person possesses it or not, you can view it as simply treating them as a long-term holder if they
stay at a certain address for more than two years
.  So, looking at the ratio of holders, I
think you can consider it to be at an all-time high.  Uh, rather than viewing this as the
correction span continuing to drag on to an all-time high, I
think it would be more accurate to say that the cycle in this river ended quickly, contrary to people's expectations.  So, people used to expect the
Bitcoin chart to show a pattern where the cycle would go on for a long while, then drop briefly, and then display a pattern resembling a double top upon a double top. However,
contrary to those expectations,
those who entered a bit late are highly likely to face losses, and as I
mentioned earlier, the realized price
is the average cost per person.
So, it means that the bottom is caught only after the average price of those people is
inevitably touched and more than
half of them enter the loss zone. Therefore,
you can view the flow as one where you can catch the next price and the bottom only when you enter that zone. In reality, since short-term
holders are currently suffering significant losses,
people are finding it
difficult to make decisions regarding this aspect.
However, I brought two charts with the idea that if the price drops sharply below its average cost, stop-
losses might occur, the price of BitGong itself could
become lighter, and we
could expect a tunneling scenario at that point
.   That's
all.  You showed us two charts regarding the major issues you explained today.
Of course, we’ll have to wait and see, but we
jokingly [clears throat]
talk about the "promised September and October." Hey, could we interpret these
charts as supporting our outlook
?   yes
.  yes.
I think you can consider it as active support.  Actually, if we look at it precisely assuming it will reach 48
points—or $48,000—and then
$52, we
could be wrong. However, since there are likely
more conservative investors or those who view Bitcoin conservatively than stock investors, from that
perspective, I believe it is actually more appropriate to wait and see if it hits $52,000 before moving forward
.  Back then, whenever I
went, the ratio of reward to floor ratio was always
high.  I just mentioned it in this context
.
All right.  Since valuing coin prices and
cryptocurrencies is
quite difficult for us, we are monitoring
them together to check market mobility and investor sentiment
.  So far, I do
n't see any signs that investment sentiment is actively reviving or that market liquidity is shifting toward Bitcoin, so it seems we are in a liquidity-driven market
.  I think it needs a little more time to ripen with water, but since we will keep
checking on it at Chaesly, I would appreciate it if you could continue to stay with us for Part 1
.  It looks like Part 1 will end a little early today
.  Since it's Monday, I have to watch the valuation in Part 2, and the
content is a bit heavy
.  We will now wrap up Part 1. We hope you will join us for Part 2 as well.
Thank you to everyone at Chamilton for being with us.  Da
[music]
เฮ
Hello.  We will begin the
second part of the Chaesley Morning Brief today, Monday, June 29, with investment expert Chesley on your journey to happy investing
.   Did
you have a happy weekend?  Ah, I heard you enjoyed watching Byeoljubu Jeon over the weekend. Yes, the day before yesterday was
three hours long, which was a lot, but even while
we were doing it, it felt like it went by in a flash, so I really
enjoyed
hosting it. I think Pro Yuri, in particular, worked
very hard.
And regarding Mr. Tabender's questions and so on, while
hosting Byeoljobujeon, I realized they are truly eccentric
people. They
love stocks, and despite having full-time jobs, they came to give
presentations. It was very
helpful to me, and I think it must have been helpful for the viewers to review the past
week and forecast the market for the coming week
.  It is.  Now,
President Choi, what materials did you
bring?
yes.  First off, the semiconductor sector
experienced another sharp decline on Friday.  There was another surge after
Icon Technologies announced its earnings on Thursday
.
Amidst all this sharp fluctuation, if you look at the sectors, there were
quite a few that rose.  So,
currently, including today and tomorrow, there are
two trading days left in the first half.  And given the
current situation where market concentration is quite severe, I think that, just as
Pro Yuri mentioned this morning, rebalancing, the suppression
of concentration, and leverage liquidation are all
interconnected
.  Ah, it does
n't seem like there were any particular issues with individual stocks
.  So,
looking at the overall current position of the market, the P&
G Grade Index is currently maintaining a peer area, and
furthermore, in the extreme fear zone
.  This has been continuing for several days now.
If you compare it with the SMP
500 next to it, which is the red line, we are
observing the B&G grid continuing to move in a fear zone even as it hits new highs. This
appears to be due to a concentration of trading in certain sectors.  It
appears to be a case of the end. Since this excellent
grade index actually
compares rising and falling stocks, or stocks reaching new highs or record highs, it
tends to enter a peer zone when such trends become extreme.
Therefore, as the concentration continues in certain IT sectors, such as
AI infrastructure and AI semiconductors, it is
judged that the market is entering a peer zone.  So, in conclusion,
looking at just that Friday, it seems that the concentration on the semiconductor sector, the
process of overheating,
profit-taking, leverage liquidation, and rebalancing all coincided
seasonally. If
you look at the general indices, the
daily returns generally dropped from the low to
mid-single digits
to as much as double digits. However, in the
case of On Semiconductor, which fell by more than 20%, it was not particularly unusual considering the issue of acquiring about
20% of its shares through a stock issuance,
so taking dilution into account, a
drop of over 20% was
not a particularly special event.
Memory storage devices that rose by 200% to 700% this year when viewed by characteristics.
And Micro, that is, stocks like Micro
Technologies, SanDisk, Western Digital, and
Seagate have
fallen by more than 6 to 10 percent.
And as I mentioned earlier, Onsemi
recorded a 20% drop due to acquisition rights.
Looking at the sector performance of the SP 500, we observed a rebound in old economy stocks—which
are on the opposite side of IT infrastructure or semiconductors
and had been relatively neglected since the beginning of the year—such as healthcare, consumer discretionary, real estate, and consumer staples. Additionally, we
observed a rebound in stocks that had been overlooked.
So, I think it is correct to view this as a
supply and demand or psychological factor rather than a fundamental one. In the
case of RSP, which tracks an equal-weighted index, we observed a divergence of sectors and stocks over the past five days. As a
result, its relative performance was about 4% better compared to SPY, which tracks a market capitalization index. I believe this also
explains the divergence of sectors and stocks, the alleviation of concentration, and rebalancing
.  On the other hand, regarding
XLV, which estimates the healthcare index,
XLU, which estimates Excel-type utilities, and
XLK, which estimates IT—that is, the
sectors that were previously neglected in healthcare and utilities—there has recently
been a strong rebound, while the IT sector has
recorded a relative decline. You can view this as the two
sectors showing
divergent relative performance in
the short term
.
So, I have brought Micron and the
Philippines Index EPS valuations. The
reason I specifically brought these is that Micron
Technology announced very surprising earnings last Thursday, and I wanted to see
how this affected the Philippines Index,
how much upward adjustments were made to Micron's EPS, and what its
valuation stands to be, as it is a
representative stock within the semiconductor sector.
Overall, the Philippines Index
fell 7.9% on a weekly basis
.  However, the PR itself ranged
from 27.8 times to 24.8 times.  Of course, there may
be a situation where the PR has decreased due to the decline in the stock price, but considering the 3.3%
upward adjustment, you
can view it as the drop in the stock price being significant compared to the upward adjustment of the EPS.  So, you
can consider that the PER has also decreased a bit.  Uh, if you look at Mycon
Technology, ah, regarding PR,
well, in the case of the PhilPhilBan Index, the
previous high went up to about 29.1 times,
but
recently, due to the stock price decline and upward
adjustment of EPS, it has come down to 24.85 times, uh
, slightly breaking below 25 times
.  You
can consider it as the valuation burden having decreased a bit
.  yes.  The reason is, uh,
Micron's recent performance...   It
appears that the announcement contributed significantly to the upward revision of the Philippine Index's EPS.  Mycon Technology has experienced
significant fluctuations, with a
drop of about 0.1% over the past week.   The
PER
dropped from 10.8 times a week ago to 8.2 times. The
reason for this is not that the stock price fell,
but that the EPS was adjusted upward by 4% from 32.4% over the past
week, and as this
upward adjustment occurred in a stepwise manner, it
had the effect of lowering the PER.  So,
overall, the
Philippine index EPS rose in line with the upward revision of Micron Technology's EPS
.  And as the stock price
decline accompanied it, you can consider the P-multiple to have been present,
albeit minimally, compared to the general index and microconvention technology
.
So, some investment banks—like JP Bank—have
suggested barbell strategies to reduce short-term volatility, as there is a possibility of sector corrections during the process of easing market concentration, rather than adhering to a general top-down strategy. While this barbell
strategy is one that emerges from major firms like Bank Up America whenever volatility increases, and it is
certainly a means to reduce that volatility, when
leading
sectors are strongly trending upward, the
rise of those sectors can actually be
offset by a decline in other sectors. Therefore, personally, I do not
mechanically
employ barbell strategies, but in my
view, I believe that the
process of easing market concentration and overheating—driven by seasonality or the influence of end-of-month, end-of-quarter, or end-of-half—is continuing in the short term
.
Accordingly, I think that as profit-taking, leverage
settlement, and rebalancing take place,
volatility might subside somewhat. Also, just
before Samsung Electronics' earnings announcement, there
was Micron, but I believe the preliminary earnings announcements and the
V-Tech earnings previews will serve as
turning points, and I
think the resilience of existing stocks will be strengthened.
Also, the exact date has
n't been set yet, but since
July 4th is Independence Day, it is normally
closed, and July 4th falls on a Saturday.
So, July 3rd has been designated as a substitute holiday, so the
U.S. market will be closed.
Even on July 2nd, only the class president's meeting is
held.  Uh,
since the market closes at 1:00 PM US time, you can assume that the
US market this week will be open for about three to three and a
half days
.  So, regarding Tesla's
earnings—or rather, the quarterly
sales figures—it
seems like they will be released around the 1st or 2nd of this week. While it
used to serve as an important barometer for overall growth stocks, its
presence has diminished somewhat lately.
However, if we take a look at it in advance as a stock belonging to the M7 group
,
Ah, regarding the announcement of second-quarter sales figures,
the market
is estimating the sales volume to be around 396,000 units.  It is a
figure that increased by about 4 million won from 358,000 units in the last quarter.
This is the number increased by 3.2% for Y.
And the operating
profit margin is expected to be 4.59% in the second quarter based on the consensus
.  We expect it to improve by about
0.4 percentage points compared to the previously reported 4.2%
.  Ah, the
important thing to look at is cash flow, and
operating cash flow is projected at $3.29 billion
.  And
the market estimates that Capital Expitcher has been around 6.5 billion for 5 years
.  So, you can consider that a
significantly larger amount of CAPEX
has been used compared to before, and
accordingly, the operating cash flow is estimated at -3.8
billion dollars
.  But if
you look at what comes after that, it's
Capital Expand.  So, since CAPEX is
expected to be around $7.7 billion to $17 billion in the third quarter, and the
market views Tesla's CAPEX as continuously increasing starting this quarter, the company had
previously
recorded consistently positive figures in free cash flow.
Because of this, it was evaluated as being financially sound,
but as CAPEX is
expected to continue increasing quarter by quarter,
the market
seems to be anticipating that it will also affect the cash flow of operating surplus.
I think we'll have to wait and see.   I don't
think there will be any major changes in terms of sales, but
for now, I think the
stock price momentum will be influenced by how the KEPFIX part turns out in the earnings announcement
.  First of all, if
you look at the stock price and Tesla's P, the current
stock price has fallen by about 6% year-to-date, from 15.6%
.
If you look at the second quarter, EPS is set to
increase by about 8.6% to $0.43 on a yearly basis
.  And regarding the 0.5 yen in the third quarter,
the market estimates that it will steadily increase when viewed quarter by quarter
.  Currently, PR
is trading at about 176 times its value.  In the case of the previous low, it was about
160 times.  So, just like with
other big tech companies, I think the sensitivity
investors feel regarding CAPEX could
increase significantly in the future
.  That's all.   hmm.
When is the earnings announcement?
Well, as for the earnings announcement, ah, it seems to be around the
20th of July.  July 20th
Gyeongye.  Yes. This yes.  The exact date has
not been set.  So far.  yes.
Looking at Tesla's stock EPS right now,
yes.   The
white one is EPS stock,
yes.
Uh, while other sectors like semiconductors have recently been
showing an upward trend in EPS with profit estimates jumping high every time earnings are announced,
yes.  Tesla just
drops sharply like a waterfall every now and then, then
comes back up, and drops sharply again. Seeing
how it keeps lowering its lows, it seems there
wasn't much of a shock with each earnings announcement
.  It seems that a pattern is continuing where people get a little hopeful whenever earnings are announced, but then the
actual
results fall short of expectations.
Furthermore, regarding
Elon Musk's
vision, which is crucial, since concrete
numbers are not being provided to support that vision, EPS rises
again due to expectations only to be adjusted downward
.
That's true.  paper.
yes.  That is correct.
And as mentioned here, the
cash flow was negative by about $3.8 billion this time, so there is
n't much to see next quarter either, right?
yes.   hmm.
So, as you mentioned, there are many dreams, but the
numbers aren't coming out right now. Also,
regarding the increase
in CAPEX, both Tim Cook and
Elon Musk are expressing their frustration over the
rebound in die memory prices—not just a rebound, but a
surge and skyrocket.
Everyone is talking about this and that, but rather
than saying that Q has doubled, it seems that
costs
have increased by this amount simply because memory prices have skyrocketed
.  Yes, that part will
contribute significantly.  yes.
So,
from the perspective of companies that need to keep investing—especially those that
rely on memory—it is highly likely that there will be
another shock when they announce their earnings this time, as their profits will likely be lackluster
.
I have this thought.
yes.  hmm.  On the other hand, I recently had the opportunity to experience the Tesla Model
X's autonomous driving again
.
yes.
Uh, after that experience, I was going to
work this morning and a Model X was driving in front of me, and
uh, now it looks different.
Well,
the car looks different, and the autonomous driving adds details that make you think, "Wow, I didn't realize it was already at
this
level."
So, when we consider things like
autonomous driving in actual services or human-like robots that will eventually infiltrate our lives,
that distant future actually feels
more concrete and
believable. It
seems that stock prices are moving based on that belief.  yes.  As for how I’m thinking about that branching point, it’s just my fish...
[clears throat] You know, Robot City is
going around right now.  There is still a co-
driver next to me.  I think the day when assistant drivers
disappear is the
point at which complete autonomous driving is finally realized.  I believe there would be a
massive surge in the stock price at the point when we could remotely control a car from home to park in front of our building, or utilize idle vehicles commercially like Uber. However,
since those developments are being delayed or the momentum is
somewhat
weak, I think the
stock price is still languishing
.   Yes,
that Tesla person said that.
Ah, people say it feels like a waste of money when calling a designated driver after drinking. Even when the
driver actually arrives, they just set it to
autonomous driving and it drives on its own,
but since a driver is absolutely necessary, yes,
so we do call a driver, but it
seems technology has advanced to such an incredible level that people feel like it is a waste of money.
Yes, that is correct. Yes, yes.  You know,
from 99 points to 100 points, I think scissors are a bit
scary.   It's the
hardest.
yes.
Okay, so we've looked at Tesla's stock price trends, and also the
recent rises and falls of individual semiconductor stocks. The
market itself is currently heading toward extreme peerage
.  A somewhat peculiar market is unfolding
.
Recently, the SP 500
dropped 2% in 5 days, the Nasdaq
dropped 4.6%, and over the past month, it
fell 5.1% and 1%.
Yes, it does
n't look that weak recently, but the
AND index, which is built on market sentiment and various volatility, is currently in extreme peer mode
.  In Korea, too,
phenomena are occurring where the KOSPI index is showing strangely high figures
.
Nevertheless, it is encouraging that the 10-year government bond yield has
fallen to 4.37%, breaking below 4.4%
.  Oil prices have dropped to 69.4,
so why can't the market
rise in a pleasant way?  It seems that this is causing frustration for
those currently participating in the market
.  Because one side is
too strong and the
other is heavily
concentrated, and consequently
leverage, margins, and similar
factors are heavily skewed, side
effects can
manifest severely in the short term. Therefore, it seems likely that market
participants would
feel a great deal of psychological anxiety
.
yes.
Now, despite that, if we look at the biotech sector, we can see it
surging very strongly. It would be
difficult for the biotech sector to rise if it entered a complete bear market,
but since we are seeing stocks hitting new highs in the biotech field, I am
looking into whether there is a shift in the leading stocks within this sector. And now, there are only
two days left in the first half of 2026.
yes.  There are two days left.
The market was quite dramatic during the first half of the year, wasn't it?
yes.   I think I
did the lyrics section like that too.   Since you
mentioned bio, if
you look at the healthcare sector within the SMP Sector 500, you can see that the SP
500 generally includes a lot of major stocks
. Since it includes companies like Johnson & Johnson, John Securities, and Lilly, it is
somewhat different from the
biotech sector generally perceived; it is a bit old-fashioned. Because it contains large pharmaceutical stocks with solid earnings and earnings power, if you
look at the P/E ratio, it is only
18.6 times.   That's right
.  It is somewhat of an essential consumer product
.  yes.
yes.  Yes, in bio
.  So, it has good cash generation capabilities,
and as a result, it occasionally performs well and offers
quite decent dividends. Because of this, it
seems to be on a different level compared to biotech stocks that rely solely on new drug development
.
yes.  [Snoring] Okay, then let's leave the
domestic and US markets here.
Ah, let's not talk about valuation undervaluation.  yes.
Recently, there has been a bit of a correction trend in both the US and Korea, and
SM has fallen 2% over the past week.
Ah, it fell 2%, and the 10-month Board
EPS rose by about 1% (there is a typo here)
.  And YTD
rose 7.4%.  10-month
board EPS was revised upward by 7% to 18.7%
.  As of June 26, the
PR is recording 19.94x to 94x
.  The PBR is recording 5.5 times
.  Uh, the
PR of the SP 500 has now
dropped a bit below 20x.
If you look at the fluctuation rates, prices
generally declined last week because the overall market was in a correction mood
.  Among them,
Ararili rose 10%.  Burke
SA rose 1.9% and JP Morgan rose
1.2%. Among the top market capitalization stocks, these kinds of
things went up a bit.
And for the rest, the atmosphere was a bit of adjustment
.
If you look at the earnings side, everything else is
just fluctuating, but as I
mentioned earlier, Mycon Technology's
EPS increased by 32.4% over the past week
.  If you look at the PR, everyone has
become very kind.  Ah, NVIDIA went
down to 18.3x, 3x, Apple to 30.1x, Google to 22.8x, Microsoft to 19.1x, Amazon to 21.4x, and Roadcom to 22x.
Tesla is at 176.8x,
Meta at 14x, and Micron has dropped to 8.2x, while
Lyri is at 30x and Bucks SA is at
25.2x
.  Generally, we are observing that
valuations in the IT sector appear to be somewhat suppressed, with the leading digits
shifting. However, it
seems that the actual results will show a slightly different pattern compared to the earnings previews.  I have a feeling that companies will simply be divided into those that
spend a lot of money and
make a lot of money, and those that spend a lot but don't make any money
.
Looking at the sector trends,
major sectors that had been strong, such as semiconductors and IT communications,
recorded weakness. As for essentials, healthcare,
utilities, and homebuilders, as I
mentioned, there is a tendency for homebuilders to strengthen when interest rates fall;
last week,
homebuilders rose by 5.8%
.   As I
mentioned earlier, regarding the e-pass,
there was an influence from the A-P-S, and overall, it
is showing a trend of not increasing.
If you look at the economic indicators,
housing price data for 20 cities is being released this week.
Looking briefly, housing prices are expected to rise by about 0.9% to 9%, and the
ISM manufacturing PMI is
projected to record 53.9
.  However, from my perspective,
since the manufacturing sector is currently in a good state, I
think it might go a bit too far
.  And
oh, employment indicators are coming out on Thursday, July 2nd, and the
labor market rate is expected to be 4.3%
.  And
as for the wage growth rate, 3.5% is
expected.
And regarding the
increase in non-agricultural employment, which
was a huge surprise last time at 172,000, the market expects that it will
slow down slightly this time to 115,000
.
U.S. 10-year
Treasury yield spread.  The U.S.
6-year 10-year Treasury fell 8 basis points to 4.37%.   The
U.S. 2-year Treasury bond also fell to
4.09%.  Long-term and short-term interest rate spread 28b.
Expected inflation fell 6 basis points to
2.2%, and the real interest rate fell 2 basis points to
2.16%.   In the
case of Hild, it rose 7bp to
6%. The filed spread is recording
2.83%, up 17vp
.  Last week, as the
stock market seemed to be in a correction phase, a
phenomenon was observed where the Hi-Yield and Hi-Yield spreads were rising slightly.
Looking at the commodities market, oil prices
have fallen below $70; in fact, they recorded
$69.2, down 10.5% last week alone
.  Copper
fell 2.9% to $6.14,
U.S. natural gas rose 2.6% to
$3.28, and European natural gas
fell 2.4% to €41.09; however,
generally speaking, since natural gas prices in both
the U.S. and Europe are fluctuating around the bottom, I do
n't think these figures are very significant
.  Looking at the dollar index, it
recorded 101.36.  It
rose by 0.5% last week.
Looking at the markets of major countries, it seems they are gradually weakening, perhaps because the dollar is strong
.   The
dollar-won exchange rate rose 0.5% to
1,535.2 won.
And as for the Euro-Dollar, it
recorded 1.138 dollars per Euro, down about 0.8% last week;   In the
case of the dollar-yen N, it recorded 73N at
161.73N per dollar, up 0.28%
.  It is currently
trading slightly above 160N,
and you can consider that the yen's weakness is continuing
.
Oh, looking at the KOSPI, the decline over the past week was
quite significant, falling 7.1%.   The
12-month forward EPS
was revised upward by 2.3%, and the
KOSPI rose 6% year-to-date to 99.6%
.  12-month EPS
was used at 156.1%.
As of June 26, PR was recorded at 7.8 times
and PBR at 2.4 times
.   As for the
growth rate, it generally declined
.  Hyundai Motor
fell by 21.6%, and Samsung C&T
rose by 0.6% even as the market declined.  And SK
rose by 12.6%.   It
seems that overall, it was a market heavily influenced by supply and demand and sentiment, so the range of rises and falls varied significantly across different stocks.
If you look over here, Samsung Electronics
has been revised upward by 2.5% and SK Hynix by 4.4%.
As for the rest, SK Square 2.0% and 0%, and
Samsung Electro-Mechanics was also reported to use as much as 6.4%
.
Samsung C&T was also used at 7.7%.
I think you can refer to this first.  As
you can see, Micron
was trading at about 8 times its leverage earlier, while
Samsung Electronics is trading at 6.4 times and SK
Hynix at 7.1 times
.  SKS fell slightly to 5.7 times, and
Samsung Electro-Mechanics to 79.7 times
.
Hyundai Motor recorded 10.3 times, Samsung Life Insurance
23.4 times,
Samsung C&T 26.6 times,
LGN Sol 89.8 times, Samsung Biologics
30.8 times, Hyundai Heavy Industries 17.8 times,
SK 5.9 times, and KB 7.7 times, all recording 7 times
.
Generally, the stock price is being
observed to be gradually declining as it falls somewhat
.  Looking at domestic interest rates
on a weekly basis, the
10-year Treasury bond fell 5bp to
4.11%, the 3-year bond fell 6bp to
3.72%, and the interest rate spread between long-term and short-term funds remains at 42p
.  Among the investment funds, the
investment funds
recorded 127 trillion, a decrease of 1.4 trillion
.  There were
no particular changes for the practical user.   It is
recording 38.1 trillion.   The
weekly average trading volume increased by about 4 trillion won to
61 trillion won.
This week, the
U.S. market is expected to have a relatively short trading volume,
and there is also the
Samsung Electronics earnings announcement and
U.S.
employment figures
scheduled to be released. However, from my perspective, I am not sure if there will be anything that will have a
significant impact on the macroeconomic side
.  However, as we now
face the end of the month, quarter, and half, I
believe the market will stabilize somewhat as we move into the latter half, as rebalancing, leverage adjustments, and position liquidations gradually come to a close
.  That's all.
yes.  Thank you.
Now, looking at it, the margin lending is
still somewhat high at 38 trillion, while
the capital of the stock market is
solid at 127 trillion.
Since a large amount of funds is continuously flowing in on time, it
gives the impression that there is still plenty of ammunition.  I feel relieved that the 10-year international interest rate is fortunately
falling a bit. While looking at the
KOSPI valuation indicators, the
KOSPI EPS is
1,067 won
. Yes, that is correct.
So, it is currently 8,400, but the
PR is only 7,8800.
That is the situation.   Not
long ago, when our country's
KOSPI plummeted in April last year due to Trump's bomb tariffs,
[clears throat] it was
22,280.  Even
when it just reached 2,300, the
PR was similar to now.
yes.  So, you
're saying that the EPS was around 250 at that time.
Yes, that is correct.
Ah, it was 250, but
now that the EPS exceeds 1,000,
yes, the
actual scale of our country is four times larger.
Yes, that is correct.   It is
simple.   Now
, profits have increased significantly. Come to think of it, the
KOSPI in Korea
earned 170 trillion won the year before last, and it exceeded 1,290 trillion won last year. Yes, perhaps they did
n't earn much the year before last,
but now it is
expected to reach 900 trillion won, 1,000 trillion won, and 900 trillion won this year. So, the
biggest driving force behind the rise in Korean stocks this time was, without a doubt, the
increase in profits.   Right
?  yes.  That's right.  yes.   It
rose like this due to increased profits in the earnings details.  This is the most
correct way to view it.
you're right.  Looking at the bottom year-to-date figures, the
stock price has risen 99.6%, while
earnings estimates have been raised by
156.1%.
That alone is enough to
qualify it for a rise of over 100%
.
So, in the walk with the owner and the dog, the
owner ran ahead for 156 meters,
meaning he had already run ahead, and then the dog
followed for about 100 meters.   Right
?
yes.  That is correct.
For now, the owner is continuously maintaining contact
.  It is
showing such an appearance.   The
dollar index rising slightly to 101.36 is
somewhat concerning, and
while the high-yield spread appears to be raising its head a little, you can view the trend level itself as
still being at a
very low level
.
So, before we move on to the domestic market, the
ISM Manufacturing PMI...
well, since it's July 1st,
yes, it
was announced tomorrow.
That is correct.
So far, it has been
consistently better than expected
.   I've
lost my mind.
yes.
So, the forecast is 53.9, whereas it was
54 last month. I also
think it might go up a bit more, and since the ISM manufacturing
PMI and the number of sexual relations in Korea are
very high, we need to keep a close eye on how the results turn out
.
Because if you
look at the recently released finalized GDP figures for the second quarter, they
were revised upward by about 0.4%, or 4 percentage points, compared to the previous provisional figures.
At that time, the reason was largely due to the fact that the
infrastructure sector in CAPEX continued to
show a solid performance
.  So, I also think that this
trend of improving ISM manufacturing quality will
continue.  yes.   Now
, let's move on to the domestic market
.
[Clears throat] I
will report on last week's gold market.   The
KOSPI index closed with a sharp decline of 5.8%
.  The KOSDAQ market closed down 4%
.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors made net purchases of 8.2 trillion won
.  On the other hand, selling pressure from foreigners and institutions
was quite strong, with foreign
investors selling 600 million won over 4 weeks.
And institutions also sold nearly 4 trillion won worth of shares, and it
appeared that individual investors absorbed some of that volume.  There was a
net inflow of about 1.4 trillion won from foreign futures
.  Looking at trading trends by investor type,
foreign investors bought Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Hyundai Heavy Industries,
LG Electronics, Samsung
SDI, Jusung Engineering, and others
.  Foreign investors sold approximately
2.3 trillion won worth of Samsung Electronics and
2.3 trillion won worth of SKNIX, resulting in a
combined total of about 4.6 trillion won in sales for the two stocks
.  Other than that, I sold Samsung Electronics
preferred shares, SK, Samsung C&T,
Riga ChemBio, Alteogen, etc.  During
the period, I bought Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
SK, Winning, IPS, PSK,
Hyundai Motor, LI, DNA, etc., and
sold SK Hynix
worth 2.8 trillion won.  Other than that, I
sold Samsung Electronics.  The remainder saw
selling centered on ETFs.   A
total of eight stocks hit 52-week highs
.  Oh, on the KOSPI, Gwangju
Shinsegae and Geummo Construction hit
new highs.   It was a
day when the trend for the semiconductor materials, parts, and equipment sector was not bad, as KOSDAQ recorded new highs for PSK, VM, and Gigamis.
That's true.
But institutions and foreign investors are
beating Samsung and Hynix quite a bit.   yes
.
Now, on the other hand, looking at what foreigners are buying, it
seems they are purchasing electric vehicles, Hyundai Heavy Industries, SDI, Mobis Heavy Industries, Samsung Heavy Industries, and even Jusung Engines. And
why are foreigners suddenly
buying buses right away?   yes
.  About 300.
Now, let's take a look at the trends of major companies
.   yes
.  Friday was a very bad day, centered on semiconductor major stocks.
Apple expressed
concerns about a price hike due to selling pressure, and as a result,
big tech companies and firms like Apple will likely
feel the price burden of memory in the future, which could lead to a
slowdown in demand
.  It seems like stories like these
became quite a hot topic at Friday's market
.  Oh, Samsung Electronics
fell significantly by about 5.3%, and SK dropped by about 8%
.  And the materials, parts, and equipment
stocks below were somewhat mixed, but if
we look at the stocks that rose first, equipment stocks such as HPSP,
EOTech, Park, Wonik, and IPS were not
bad.  It seems that Reno
Industrial, Tin Engineering, ISC,
Simtech, and SNSTech showed a weak trend again tonight
.  In the IT sector,
Samsung Electro-Mechanics closed at around flat
.  It showed some strength relative to the market,
whereas LG Electronics,
LG Innotek, BH, Fine, and Mtech
closed lower.  The platform
sector also performed poorly.  Naver, Kakao, and
Kakao Pay were weak.
Decage has also dropped significantly.   There
was a 4% plunge, and the semiconductor materials, parts, and
equipment sector was also very sluggish.  With Tokyo
Electron closing down about 3%,
Urata 9%, Disco 8%, and
Advan also
falling roughly over 8%, the
Japanese stock market showed a similar trend to the domestic market
.  If you look at the automotive sector,
Hyundai Motor, Kia, Hyundai Mobis, and AutoEver
all closed lower.  I feel like I've been
losing weight for almost the entire month, and
now it has
dropped 30% on Once.  It appears that a lot of cars have
come down.  PR has also
dropped to ten times.
If you look at the consumer sector, LG in substitute cosmetics and
Cosmax in the shopping mall sector
were generally weak.  Cosmecca Korea
showed a decent performance at 3.4%.  Well, it was generally sluggish in the Pyeongwon device
.
Except for PharmaResearch, everything was weak.  APR's
stock price has also dropped significantly recently.
So it fell by 4.7% to 7%, and
based on A Once, it is recording a decline rate of about 6.8% to 8%
.  The APR has also dropped to the low 20s now
.  And the remaining
stocks are
trading at around 14 to 15 times their value, trading at significantly low valuations
.  And as the
food rate sector below showed an endless trend,
Type 3 food also fell by 2.8%
.   On
the other hand, department store and duty-free chains were
not bad.  Hyundai Department Store actually
showed signs of a slight increase
.  Shinsegae closed at a somewhat weak level
.  Well, considering the deduction from shipbuilding, if you
look at other sectors, shipbuilding stocks also performed poorly
.  Hyundai Heavy Industries, Hana Ocean, Hana
Engine, and others generally
showed a weak trend.  The
engine has dropped by as much as 15 times, bringing its valuation
down to a level almost similar to that of Hyundai Department Store
.  You can consider it to be on the same level as a distributor
[sneer]
.
And as for me, stocks like POSCO Colding, LG
Chem, LK Innovation, oil and chemical companies, and
steel companies were generally all doing poorly, and the
trend for defense stocks, including Hana Aerospace, is also very bad these days.
It fell 5%, Neck also closed, and as Hyundai Rotem plummeted 7%,
Hanayo's stock rose 20-fold
.  Rotem is also 16 times.  Well, Nex1 has
dropped by up to 35 times.  So, excluding the semiconductor materials,
parts, and equipment sector or the semiconductor sector itself, it
appears that everything has dropped significantly from a valuation perspective.  I
see quite a few growth stocks currently trading at less than 20 times their leverage. The fact that they are trading below 20 times, despite expectations of
earnings growth of over 20% over the next three years, suggests that
many of these stocks have entered undervalued territory
.  The biotech sector was also very
bad.  Starting with the KOSPI biotech sector, the
KOSDAQ also
saw a sharp decline due to short selling.  As for securities stocks, I remember Kiwoom
Securities rebounding strongly on Thursday, but it
plummeted immediately on Friday.  It closed down about 9%, and the
entertainment sector is also
continuing its sluggish trend, while SM
is tenfold.  And I remember the transformer sector doing
pretty well at the beginning of the session,
but as the market entered the thinning phase, the
decline widened across the board, and transformers, including Hyundai 1-Rex,
dropped significantly.
So, it’s not easy to see a Hyundai 1-leg 30-ship break, but it
broke.
Hey, I'm looking at the Chosun Iron & Steel sector right now, and
this is based on a one-month period, you know.   yes
.   It's meant to be
caught.   yes yes
.
Wow, you've lost a lot.
And if you look at the stock market, not only Kiwoom
Securities but also Mirae Securities has
dropped significantly.  If you look at recent
trends, right?
In a way, since our country's financial assets seem to be
continuously shifting toward the administration, it could be
seen as having entered a phase of structural growth. However, given that
stock prices have dropped by 30%,
honestly, what I find myself wondering is, just how
exactly should it be?  I mean that
perspective.  This
doesn't mean the administration is over.   That's right
.   There are
probably many of you holding securities stocks, and at this
level, we need to assess the valuation.
The evidence for Kiwoom right now is that PR is
PR.   It's up
5 to
5.4 times, and
KB Financial is up 7.7 to 7 times, but the
financial sector has
n't dropped much.
Stocks have recently dropped significantly, so
those who are stuck with them are
very worried about what to do.  With Samrikje, I threw up almost everything I had
eaten lately.  Many people are saying this, and the same goes for the shipbuilding industry;
most sectors have been
dumped out.
Overall, the market sentiment appears
somewhat weak. If we
look into the reasons for this weakness, there really isn't one other factor besides
central banks around the world recently raising interest rates
.
There isn't any, but
last time in 2022, when they
raised interest rates to 5.5%, they sent out a
doctorate in faith. It was the same in the past, in
79 and the 80s. Regarding
how high this S&P raises interest rates, as I mentioned once in *The Tale of the Turtle and the Cow*, I
said you can think of it like the temperature of a bathtub.  Even if I raise it, if I only
turn it up to about 39, 40, or 41 degrees, I
think, "Ah, it's warm," and it feels good. But if it
reaches 45 or 46 degrees, is it
inevitable that it gets hot and pops out?  So,
this ended up becoming a pivot to raise interest rates
.  rather.  yes.
Until early this year, there was an expectation that rates might be lowered one or two more times, but
since the situation has instead become one where rates must be raised,
the market is trembling and
currently declining. If we
consider how high rates will be raised,
international
interest rates move first in the 10/16 10-minute intervals;
having gone down to 4.6%, the 4.4% level is now being
breached. Therefore, even if there is an interest rate hike
this time, it will likely only happen once or twice.
Consequently, I think we need to
carefully look for stocks that are attractive in terms of valuation
.  From the bottom, and then there is another thing: there was a
correction in August of 2024 as well, wasn't there?   That's right
.  Even in 2024, the market dropped once in August due to the
liquidation of carry trades and such.
In the past, the momentum of a bull market that was
doing well was suddenly
broken
in August 2011 when the US credit rating was downgraded.
Since there are a lot of events happening in August and September, looking at the 100-year history of the NASDAQ,
the market has generally performed poorly in September
.  So I have a bit of trauma regarding this third quarter
.  As a result, on top of that, it is an even-numbered year with
midterm elections, and
cryptocurrencies like Ethereum have
dropped by more than 40% since the beginning of the year.  Bitcoin is also
down 35%.
So, there is a bit of risk aversion,
especially
due to trauma from the third quarter.
So I got sidelined, and recently I’ve had
various
lectures scheduled, such as on the JoongAng Ilbo’s "Investment & Visiting Man" segment. The title is "The
Crisis in the Stock Market in the Second Half."
So, regarding what this crisis is, you know how I
mentioned that the gray area is interest rates?
But when the gray market rushed
at us like in '22, big tech companies and everything else would
drop by 70%.
Now, look at that gray market; will it
charge at us again,
or will it just wander around over there
peacefully grazing on grass before leaving? Well, it does glance this way
once. Since the
central bank is raising interest rates, it takes a big step over here. Yes, it did approach, but it
won't charge at us like it did in '22.  I expect that
.  Ah, then, let's
take a look at the report.
It's a Samsung Electronics report.  What cards does LS Researcher Jung Woo-sung have
left?   Upon
reviewing the details, an opinion was presented suggesting that the
impact on server DRAM supply and demand within the first half of the CXMT period might be somewhat
limited
.  It was predicted that concerns regarding the expansion of the 2027-2028 business could be highlighted due to the CXMTA listing and funding-based
certificates
.  However, even if Chinese companies
secure processes of 15nm or smaller, we
believe it is unlikely that they will alleviate the supply and demand for high-performance server DRAM in the short term
.  It is said that server-type DRAM
must simultaneously satisfy customer certifications regarding performance, power efficiency, and yield, in addition to meeting fine process requirements. Furthermore, it is reported that China
faces technological limitations in areas such as advanced furnace equipment and core optical materials, as it has not been able to secure the necessary equipment.  Therefore, while
CXNT's expansion
may affect the supply of general-purpose DRAM, the opinion is that it will likely take considerable time before it can
directly compete with the electronics industry in the advanced server DRAM market
.   It is said that while there is talk of
expanding policy support for AI investment in the U.S., measures to publicly share the achievements of the AI ​​industry through the utilization of sovereign wealth funds
and securing support for AI companies are
becoming established in the U.S.  They say that
specific systems or
financing structures have not yet been finalized
.  It is considered a move demonstrating that AI infrastructure is
recognized as a national strategic industry beyond private investment, and it is also seen as
positive that discussions are continuing to support the continuation of investment rather than tightening equipment export regulations or price controls despite rising memory prices.  It seems highly likely that this will act as a factor
lowering the financing burden on Big Tech, favorable market conditions,
and extending the book value jealousy period for Samsung Electronics
.  It is said that securing the positive outlook of HM is more important than second-quarter earnings, and
I
predicted that the second-quarter results would reflect the lagging increase in mobile PCM contracts, which saw limited growth in the first quarter, along with the base effect related to performance science.  Accordingly, while short-term earnings
improvement is expected to continue, we believe
the market has already largely reflected this in the stock price due to the anticipated profit growth driven by the current favorable memory market
. Ultimately, we view securing HBM mass production as the key to generating additional excess returns.   It was
suggested that if H expansion is confirmed through customer certification and repair, a reduction in earnings estimates or a valuation reduction is expected to be possible simultaneously.
CXMT is
preparing for an IPO, and it seems that the company's efforts to
secure future competitiveness in DRAM through capital raising and equipment purchase certificates are acting
as some noise in the current market from the perspective of our semiconductor industry
.  First off,
LS Securities analyst Jung Woo-sung
seems to have predicted that it is still too early to worry about this aspect.  So,
looking at the estimates that are gradually emerging, I
saw in Researcher Song Myeong-seo's previous data that there was
information on the annual DRAM market share based on the amount of losses.
According to industry reports, the electronics sector is
also estimated to be around 30% to 33% based on the second half of 2026
.  They said that Scania would
rise to 30%, Micron to about 27%, and China to around 10%.
So, anyway, in terms of market share, China has been
increasing its share by almost 5 or 6 percentage points over the past two years.  Looking at that aspect,
if the demand for AA semiconductors
declines, it means we ultimately have to
look to the PC and mobile sectors again, does
n't it?  Then, the Chinese side will come up from there
.   Could
n't this act as a risk factor in the future?  But I
don't think we are in that phase right now. Since the demand for AI is so
solid, we need to be cautious when it takes a downturn
.
I had that thought a bit.  If you look at the table below,
I have included the CAPEX figures for Samsung Electronics, SK Hynix, and
Micronetworks, as well as future
forecasts, based on Bloomberg.   The
blue line represents Samsung Electronics, the
white line represents SK Hynix, and the red line represents
Micron.
Looking at it, I noticed that Micron is making quite a lot of CAPEX investments
.  It will be done next year at almost the electronic level
.  It is
being estimated, and although the number is small so you might not be able to see it clearly, according to
Bloomberg estimates, it is currently around 80 trillion won
.  The CAPEX
estimate.  And Samsung Electronics is also
projected to invest about 80 trillion won in CAPEX, and SK Hynix about 55 trillion won
.
But why is it trending downwards like this?
Ah, this is a negative... I mean, it's an investment.
Looking at all the CAPEX investments, the bigger the negative, the better
.  Ah, so that's because it's displayed as a minus sign
.
So, it means they are continuing to invest more aggressively, by this amount
.   yes
.  It feels like we are doing about 40 trillion this year
.  From 40 to 50. And as
for next year, I originally saw
estimates early in the first half that said we would invest about 50 to 60 trillion in electronics next year,
but looking at it lately, it seems to be
increasing to about 80 trillion [laughs]. As expected, regarding
investment, it is
highly likely that CAPAC investments will be more active this
year and
next year than we previously anticipated.   However, we are actually
investing more than the estimates for next year and this year as well.
It seems the magnitude itself will be larger next year, but
looking at the data from those sources,
the supply shortage might be resolved starting around the second half of 2027
.  They are talking about things like this.   For now, as of this
year, the growth rate of
demand is still higher than the growth rate of production,
so there is no need to worry about that, but if
supply
increases next year, and if it happens in 2020 or so, we
need to be careful.
Stories like this have been
appearing quite often in industry reports recently.   They say they will do the
Bible study at the end of July.   yes
.  The
discussion from last Friday is that the final report will be submitted to Jeju on Thursday, July 1st,
and the surveying will begin next week.   yes
.  Regarding the area, that institution, and then the individual,
then it could take roughly two weeks, right?   If so, around the
20th of the last week of July,
which Hong Kong market is it listing on then?
It is correct in the mainland of this market.  But regarding the back pain, the frequency of back pain is
n't that high.  At the beginning, there was
probably only 3%.
3%
Yes.  It is a tradable
stock that can fluctuate.   Only
institutions can do it, and individuals cannot buy it
.
Individuals can't buy it.   yes
.  Since Hyunhoo has the issue of index inclusion,
there is a possibility that the volatility of its market capitalization could increase significantly.
Because originally, it could come out to 130 billion
.  130 billion.  Uh, I'm
looking at about 200 million next year and about 300 million the year after.
what?  Net profit.
Net profit.  Uh, if 300 million is
300 million, then 60 trillion.
60 trillion.
Is it 60 trillion?   yes
.  60 trillion.  It
was estimated that way in 2028.  60 trillion.   yes
.  We have to see how things turn out then,
but Chinese semiconductor companies
receive PR about 50 times starting from the Vice Presidential Office.
But that [clears throat] if we consider the future,
so if we apply it 50 times here,
uh, 350. That's
almost 2,000
. Right. Yes, yes.  Well, if you calculate it like this, you can get this result
.
Since you don't have much back pain in the beginning, the
captain's work will probably be heavy, and you will go
until the end.   I suppose
so.  Rather, because the number of shares in circulation is
low, there is a
possibility that the stock price could surge even with just a slight surge in buying pressure
.  yes.  The upper limit for the inland market is 10%
.
Ah, since this is the first day,
uh, it doesn't apply on the first day.
From the next day, it's 10%,
then the week after that, so is this a
luxury for selecting the Gwacheon class? Therefore,
the upper and lower limits become plus 20%.
Ah, yes, it's plus or minus 20%
.
If it weren't for i-Changsin Memory and Yang Memory, there really wouldn't be
much to be afraid of. Samsung Electronics,
Hynix, and Micro-Mechanics have already fully optimized everything, and as for the
front-end demand, there is going to be massive
demand continuing for the next five years or so
.
That is correct.  So there is nothing to worry about. With the listings of Changxin and
Yangdian Hammer, there
is aggressive capacity expansion.
So, the key question now is
when the market price will collapse. Although it is said that this
team and others have asked to be allowed to use
Chinese semiconductors, the
truth is that
China is also busy with its domestic consumption.  Right?   yes
.  Well,
so that actually makes no sense. We are keeping them,
but if we
sell them at too high a price, people will say, "Oh, I'll just use Chinese ones
." However, overall, things are getting ugly in both China and the US right now, so I understand.  Also, since we have
plenty of time to continue here, let's move on.
Next, let's take a look at the Hyundai Rotem report
.
Uh, we talked a bit about the second-quarter earnings
.  It seems expectations will be met, and the
title was "Juka Back to the Bottom of the Box Range."  It
was data from Hana Securities.  The TP
was set at 283,000 won, and it
is a buy.  We
expect second-quarter earnings to be in line with market consensus, and we anticipate that growth in the defense sector will continue, driven by
the recognition of revenue from the mass production of Polish KT's secondary systems
.  Now, meanwhile, it is said that the company's stock price is
moving within a range of 165,000 won, 50,000 won, and 282,000 won in the second half of 2025, which corresponds to a
level of 18 to 28 times based on forward P-net
.  The current stock price has
fallen back to the lower end of the Ford P/E ratio, at 18 times.  I fell even deeper on Friday and
dropped to about 16 times.  It is said that it is subject to the lowest valuation among the five domestic defense companies, and
even considering the recent market environment where stock prices continue to rise centered on specific sectors, Rotem's undervaluation within the defense industry can
ultimately be
seen as a result of reflecting concerns about its performance.  The Defense
Solutions division general believes that there will be no
major difficulties in mid-to-long-term performance growth with approximately 10 trillion won
.  However,
considering the delivery schedule, it is judged that
tangible defense export results must be secured by the second quarter of 2027 to
resolve concerns regarding short-term performance
.  In particular, I said that we should avoid excessive concern regarding the
Middle East order pipeline, which is the most important in the short term,
as it is considered a matter of timing rather than the likelihood of securing orders
.  So, they are
definitely going to leave Iraq, but there is
no way to know when that will be.  But anyway, it
seems like the story is that this will be released.  We projected a second-quarter profit of
around 280 billion won and
expected it to be close to the consensus.   The
order backlog for the Rail Solution and Eco-Plant divisions is said to be approximately
18.5 trillion, 0.8 trillion, and 8 trillion won, respectively
.  The
Defense division, a core business unit, is projected to see sales of 1 trillion won, an
increase of approximately 32% compared to the previous year
.  This is attributed
to the expansion of revenue recognition for the second mass production of the Polish K-1000 car. Based
on this standard, we
expect the operating profit to be around 289 billion won, with an operating margin of 17%, an increase of 11.9% and 9% respectively compared to the previous year, and a decrease of 1.1 percentage points
.  We have set aside some funds for costs until the first half
due to the second phase of local production in Poland, but we
expect that profitability to continue until around the second quarter.  On the other hand, the
majority of recent forecasts suggest that once we move into the fourth quarter, the market capitalization for the second volume is likely to rise in a stepwise manner, just like before.   I
also talked about Romanian tanks.   They say there has
n't been much progress yet and that it is currently in
progress.  The Romania tank
project is worth about 9 trillion won, and as a large-scale
project, it
can be seen as a key order momentum for Rotem, along with the Iraq and Peru projects
.  In September 2025, the Romanian
Ministry of Defense submitted an unexpected request for project approval
.  It is said that
tank projects have not been included in the list of projects eligible for S-type financing since last January, and
this can be seen as a factor that raises expectations for the acquisition of Rotem compared to German companies, which are
relatively separate in terms of local production conditions when utilizing loans
.  They say there has
n't been any concrete progress yet.   It is understood that
Romania is currently reviewing candidate tanks. It is reported that in
June, Romania signed a 5.7 billion dollar contract with Rheinmetall for
combat vehicles, defense systems, and ammunition.
Concerns are being raised that this contract, which utilized foreign loans, allows Rheinmetall to secure Romania's local production network, potentially shifting the tank business in favor of the German company
.  However, since this contract and the tank
project are being pursued separately, it was even suggested that the
direct impact on the tank project is
still limited
.   If
you take a look at the performance figures below, they show sales revenue
, profit, and operating profit margin on a quarterly basis
.
Uh, the impact on the second shipment volume has been
appearing since the fourth quarter of last year and into the first quarter of this year, but if we
look only at the operating profit margin, the current
trend is not very good.
Because it keeps coming down quarterly.  So, 10
[snorting] 18.2 in the second quarter of last year,
then 17.1, 16.5,
15.4, 3 4. It seems that the current estimate is that there will still be some rebound in the second quarter
.
We expect margins to recover further in the third and fourth quarters. As I mentioned earlier,
since local production in Poland is now becoming repetitive, it can be
seen that the outlook incorporates the expectation that costs will be more controllable than before
.  On the right is a
graph showing performance trends and a
table of annual sales forecasts by segment; the
sales share of Defense Solutions continues to
show an increasing trend
.  Rails and eco-plants are
being maintained to that extent.
Below that are Hana Aero, Nexwon, and
Hyundai Rotem.   The
first one
is a white space.  The white one and the other have also
dropped significantly right now.  And
Hyundai Rotem is in the red, and it
has dropped to 17 or 18 times.  And
damn it, X1, ah, DNA has also
dropped by about 35 times.
So, compared to the increase in profit, the bell count
itself has definitely dropped significantly.
Well, Rhein Metal's stock price
dropped a bit earlier.  Because it was cut in half
.  Isn't there a trend showing that Rotang, Hana, and Aeronas
DNA are also coming down a bit right now
?  So, as the
valuations of global defense companies have
declined slightly, they inevitably
fell along with them. Also,
given the heavy concentration of supply and demand in the semiconductor sector, I think they have been taking a much greater hit
recently
.  So, if the semiconductor market takes a
break or turns bearish due to the concerns we have been having,
I actually think sectors like Dangsan, cosmetics,
APs,
or secondary batteries might be
good prospects for the future.  If I
take a break, I am
thinking about that.
This is a
question often asked on TV:
what sector looks promising after semiconductors
?  I get asked these kinds of questions all the time, and thank you for even telling me
that. As for me, regarding
Hyundai Rotem, I’ve been looking through the charts and have been taking a
break for almost six months now,
right? Yes, that is correct.   The
reason we reduced our stock holdings last year around July, when we were debating whether it was the right move, was because we are structurally invested.   hmm.   You're the
temple owner of the mine structure, aren't you?  Right?   The
same goes for Chosun. This time, it's a Chosun
Upcycle Plus Masca combination,
so
those who invest long-term in structural growth stocks will probably
feel a bit frustrated because the stock price is moving sideways.   yes
.  But for long-term investors, those who hold onto that
real structural growth trend for about 5 or 10 years to make a
big profit are the ones
holding out even in phases where things don't go this way, right?  yes
.  Well, they are holding on. From the perspective of
momentum traders, they
went to shipbuilding when it was good,
went to semiconductors when it was good, and then looked to
return to shipbuilding only to find the stock prices were already way up. However,
seeing that many people are flocking to buy semiconductors, sectors like shipbuilding have
now
dropped by 40%, 35%, or 40% from their peaks. So, for
those skilled in momentum trading, they can
profit by jumping in when this stock goes up and taking profits when that stock goes down.
Therefore, on
one hand, there is significant
price merit,
but the important thing is when that turning point occurs
.  A base like this.  Last year, there was a
weak market correction in July and August,
and starting in September, as
semiconductors surged, the leading stocks began to rise
.  Some people keep saying that the
leading stock at the beginning remains the leading stock until the end
. However,
in this current high-interest rate environment, earnings-driven stocks
started early.  Right?  It
started with the defense sector, and then as
semiconductors surged forward with
tremendous profit momentum, the semiconductor
sector will continue to
rise as long as profit growth remains steep.   Because
when listed in order of profit growth rate,
money is bound to flow toward the best one
.
But the moment that profit growth rate started to drop,
while this side was happy, the other side took the
lead, and
that's how things like Samsung Electro-Mechanics went
up, right?   We should try
summoning our manager, the Prince of Joseon, here.   yes
.   More than anything
else,
rather than the question of when to switch to this side, the
growth story we saw last year is
continuing.  Or is
something damaged that caused the stock price to
drop like this?  It certainly seems likely that the
momentum for the U.S. to build warships has largely dissipated
.  Because,
originally, it passed in the Senate after the National Assembly at the end of last year, right?
yes.  I expected it to pass, but
actually, I think the biggest reason is that it didn't pass at the end of last year,
and then it was rejected again last week
.  However, if that were the case, the
story was that I would manufacture the module to some extent and send it to the U.S. to make an ARM product, but you can consider that that has definitely almost completely
disappeared
.  However, regarding the case of the engine expansion into
data centers, which we had not anticipated at all, I
believe it is actually a much larger market than the US military.   A
new market has opened up, but regarding Migunam, it is actually
impossible for us to predict at all how much profit margin will be made or what the market size will be. However,
since the engine market is a business where predictions are somewhat possible and margins are secured, it might be better to target the engine sector rather than Gunnan
.
That's true.   There's
also a
multiple attached to that place called Masaga, right?
We have to build all the U.S. warships
.  That story
was reflected in the state of Joseon, but it can be said that the bubble has completely cleared up, right?
That
bubble has now burst, so we just need to look at
how much PR is currently being received relative to earnings.
Excluding the MAS factor, then
what is the valuation of the shipbuilding industry like?
Uh, definitely, when that Mascara thing was involved,
those shipbuilding stocks kept
going up while maintaining a precise 30-fold increase.  But since most of them have
dropped to under 20x right now
, I think that engine momentum will
definitely come out
.  Because,
considering that the expansion schedule has already been set up for the palace, I think a strategy of waiting for those orders and just
accumulating them little by little would be a good idea
.
yes.   If you
profit from Jobang when the semiconductor sector fails,
profit from the semiconductor sector when it succeeds, and
profit from these guys again when they succeed this time, then that would be the
best, right?
yes.   I
hope the managers will put in a lot of effort so that we can become the best. [Laughs]  So, that concludes our look at the domestic
reports.   In the
case of Rotem right now, it was actually that
red color from earlier, right?  Uh, quite a
multiple, real band, they used to be a band, right?
Now they're out.  Yes, that is correct.
All right.  So, how is the domestic market doing
?  Looking at it earlier, the night
futures were -0.57,
and the South Korea ETF was
-3.77,
reflecting a lagging reversal of Friday's market. The
night futures ended slightly lower, but
somehow it started down by -0.91%
.  Currently, the
decline is widening further to -1.73%.   yes
.  What is happening with the KOSDAQ?   yes
.  The KOSDAQ started up 1.06%
.  Currently, it is up
to 4.6%,
4.6%.   yes
.  Uh, I don't
know about the large difference right now.
Uh, while analyzing new cars last week, it
seems like the KOSDAQ has hit a short-term bottom.  So,
looking at the situation from a technical perspective where biotech stocks suddenly rose on the KOSDAQ, it seems the KOSDAQ market
itself had
fallen to a level that hadn't been stable for 20 months.  If it drops that much, short-sleeve
purchases will come in, and I think it will
reach 4%.   Regarding
these factors, when the 10-year
government bond yield was above 4.5%, the
KOSDAQ would fall even more even if the semiconductor sector declined
.
That is correct.
However, as interest rates have fallen to below 4.4%, and we
see that a substantive game is beginning where this side actually rises once the rebound subsides, I
think that, as I mentioned earlier, the market might actually feel a bit of relief regarding the fear of interest rates going forward.
Okay, so I’m going to make a forecast for the US market tonight.
Last week,
everyone predicted that the US market would all go into the red.  Looking at it.   Were
n't they all in the negative?
Yes, that is correct.
Oh, you got them all right.   You are
amazing.  Das,
what is going to happen tonight?
I think both the SP and Nasdaq will rise tonight.   hmm.
In the futures market, the Nasdaq is currently rising a bit more, so I
think the SMP might end up rising a little further.  If you
think about the reason, I explained the
concept of beta when I denied the special stock option within Nasdaq back then on the weekend
.  So yes
.   I
split my analysis between the XLK and SMH ETFs, and I heard that SMH has a higher beta
.  semiconductor.   uh
.  However, SMH has fallen a bit more,
but since the upward movement of
SMH in futures is currently
less restricted than in Excel, and the
buying momentum in the semiconductor sector
seems weaker than expected, I think the Nasdaq will fluctuate a bit and
eventually SP will
rise more.  Seeing how
Pro Yuri does that every morning from Monday to
Thursday, and even handles the Star Market on Saturdays,
I get the impression that his interest in and focus on the market is tremendous.  I am explaining the market right now, going into
specifics about which one is stronger, the SP 500 or the Nasdaq, and for now,
both are rising.
What do you think will happen with Pilban?
I think I will be a boss.
Since Philban took another day off, did he take
two more days off?  Did you take a day off
?  8 rested.  I took a
break in August, but the drop itself was so severe that I
think I can imagine it.
Since it is the end of the first half of the year, performance among institutional investors will likely be
quite mixed. Those with
poor performance are likely to hold
fewer leading stocks and
more undervalued ones. It
seems there will be demand from these
investors, who are under pressure regarding their results, to
sell leading stocks and buy undervalued ones to "
window-dress" their portfolios
.
So, in my view, I think the KOSDAQ is showing a stronger
upward trend today due to those trends and needs
.  Looking at the US
as well, the recent strong performance of small markets
suggests
there will be demand for window dressing at the end of the month, quarter, and half.
I
expect this trend to weaken once today and tomorrow pass.  However, since the semiconductor index
fell sharply on Friday and other stocks have
risen significantly, I think that
demand might have settled down to some extent
. Therefore, I believe there might be some bargain buying or a rebound following the sharp drop in the semiconductor index.
Actually, President Choi
said that too much was lost at the semiconductor house, and
yes.  If you
compare it to other sectors you've seen so much of, uh, you should
n't say that. Other
people... well, I guess that's how it is.  No, if you
look over here, earlier one
engine stock dropped 40%, and
yes, other sectors are devastated as well. Since it
fell 5% in one day, if you talk about a
rebound in semiconductors right now because it has dropped so much,
[laughs] other companies and sectors are also just sitting
in the bushes right now.
Ah, should I be careful what I say?   Okay then, let's move on to
KOSDAQ
.  Back then, people kept
talking about bearish candles on the KOSDAQ, but
isn't today a bullish candle?  Didn't the rice come out
?
Ah, regarding the atmosphere of the Seolja Seolja score today, I
think the score likely came out as a bearish candle. Yes,
yes, that's right.  But it has improved a lot compared to before
.
Ah, it's
much better now.   The
probability score for the bearish candle is
yes.  yes.  that's right.   Well,
today I'm a beekeeper [laughs].
Uh, it looks so clear and certain, yes
.
Sudan beekeeping.   yes
So, what about the KOSPI?
friday.  Even though it's Friday, wait a
minute.  Back then, it was a Friday with a bullish candle...
or was it a bearish one?
Ah, it was a bearish candle. It's
Friday, and
today is kind of ambiguous, right?
[Snoring] It
started at 9 with -0.9 at 10 seconds, but it is
already recording a 2% drop
.   It
says here on Naver that foreigners have invested 1.38 trillion won. Is that
correct?   yes
.  About 1.67 trillion won right now.
Uh, well, it's delayed by 10 minutes.   yes
.   The
selling pressure from foreigners is a bit strong.   yes
.   Are
you hitting semiconductors?   yes
.  I do think there might be a rebound in the semiconductor sector during the trading session because the market for Samsung and Hynix is
really strong. However, regarding the fact that the
materials, parts, and sector is strong while memory is weak,
I don't see any reason for the sector to be weak, since the IPO of Changshin Memory is
coming into view and the Cheongsi market is going to
aggressively pursue Caterpillar anyway
.  That's right.
But Changshin has been here for a
long time now, so their DRAM market share is
almost 8%.
Yes.  Going over 10% next year is something that is taken
for granted, whether at Samsung or elsewhere.  Because, well, considering the
demand within China alone, the
captive market itself is huge, so it is only
natural that it exceeds 10%. But regarding the
target of reaching 20%, when exactly is that?
uh, 2028.
28 years from now... yes, yes. Since it
takes time until the expansion and production stop anyway, that is
correct.  yes.
Then, if you think about whether 20% is possible in 2028, I
think it is possible.  Because China will
use their own.  The battery was like that too,
you know.  Even though
SDI and LG Chem
have much better technology for batteries, they didn't
give them subsidies, and that was the case with batteries as well.  It
becomes 20% after 28 years.
Doesn't that slight fear regarding that kind of thing have some impact on Changsil Memory's listing?   In the
case of Hynix,
they have the right to list on ADRs, but if
Micron keeps dropping out of the ADR market, there is nothing left to
say.  Right?
[Clears throat] As we
keep making relative comparisons with Micron,
Micron’s valuation multiples have
become much higher,
but I think buying interest at those low prices will continue to come in until the ADR listing
.  Since there are two pillars to lean on—the
ADR listing and the
earnings release at the end of July—and the
results are expected to follow, I will predict a bearish candle
.  First off, today the
KOSPI has a bearish candle. Wait, did
n't they keep dragging their feet for too long before finally doing it now
?  Ah, I was going to tell you, but
ah, I kept talking [laughs].
Actually, uh, I did say I would give you some time to think, but
ah, the
market dropped even more in the meantime [laughs]
. So, I said I would make a forecast for the KOSPI annual report.
We always need to be aware that stocks are highly volatile assets,
but volatility and trend are different things.   Right
?
you're right.
yes.  So, regarding the attempt to match volatility, even I try to
predict it, and I really do get it right
.  hmm.
Rather than that, I
think it is more appropriate to align with the trend.
As for how the trend is
determined, our CEO, Mr. Choi,
provides an earnings review and preview every morning, checks the results when they are released, and predicts
how things will go in the next quarter.
Since
that actually represents the direction of the fundamentals, if
we can properly understand the volatility that appears within that trend, it becomes an opportunity to buy low and
sell high.
Therefore,
please overcome this volatility well, and we will continue to
closely monitor whether there is any damage to the fundamentals
.  Right?
yes.
Oh, and wrap up this week
well.  I hope you wrap up the first half well,
and as this week marks the start of the new second half, I
wish you continued happy and wise investing together with the investors at Choi Seon-ri.
Thank you to everyone for staying with us for this time.
thank you